rise and shine it's an espresso time
good morning relief nation it's even my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in that amazing gift you have
inside to you that needs to be shared
with the world so let's start the day
off right together grab your cup of
coffee and sit on today's message study
the game over dude Wayne the rock
Johnson when I was at the the height of
my career in the WWE I felt that for the
very first time that I was close to
accomplishing everything that I wanted
to accomplish in wrestling and I quietly
walked away kind of shook me a little
bit because wrestling was all I knew at
that time and I had dabbled in acting
but yet I also felt that I wanted to do
more and I wanted to achieve more and I
wanted to grow I wanted to grow as a
person I wanted to grow as an
entertainer and that I wanted to reach
as many people as possible not for the
box-office value of it but before the
connection and I had come from a world
where I was connecting with an audience
every night and I wanted that connection
and I wanted to not only be good as an
actor but if I made the transition into
acting I wanted to be great I knew going
in the cards are stacked against me
there's a shelf-life to a career if I
just wanted to get by on popularity
we didn't want to be in that position I
wanted longevity if that's the goal then
I have to do everything I could possibly
do to know the business of Hollywood
from top to bottom from acting to
marketing to an executive level to a
producing level to a directing level and
just know it as a whole that would
inherently make me a greater asset and I
appreciate all the people in the
beginning of my career as I was coming
up who took the time who took the effort
who took me and because I had to educate
myself and I had to be student of the
game know your business know your
business and become a student of the
game and surround yourself with
brilliant people and go to work should
you be a specialist or a generalist this
is one of the questions that comes up a
lot with entrepreneurs should you be a
jack-of-all-trades and know everything
or master one and go really deep on it
in general I like the idea that you have
Michael Jordan level talent at something
and that you need to spend as much time
as possible doing the thing that you
have Michael Jordan level talent act and
I think of it as an 80/20 rule or a
90/10 rule where 80 to 90 percent of
your time should be spent doing the
thing that you could be the best in the
world pact
and the rest that 1020 percent is doing
everything else having an understanding
I think it's good we can talk a lot
about this on a channel I think it's
good to have a general understanding
just enough to be dangerous at the other
things but that most of your time is
spent doing the big thing I think most
people will have it flip I think most
people spend 10 20 percent of their time
on the thing that they're actually
really really really really really
really really really good at and then
everything else is just grunt work crap
work stuff that just has to get done but
they never want to be the best in the
world
and as a result you don't do anything
super meaningful or special because your
time is spent doing stuff that you don't
want we're flipping that script flipping
the equation 80 to 90% of the time are
the things that you love the year you
may not be best in the world that yet
but you want to be you're gonna get
there you're gonna learn and you're
gonna try hard you're gonna invest
energy effort time hustle to get there
that's when you start creating the right
if I look at my business I know enough
to be dangerous in a bunch of different
fields but I'm not an expert at it so if
you look at the website for example I
can't code anything okay
I can't code anything I'm a sucky
programmer but I can look at code and
understand it
I can look at it and understand what the
functions are doing so that I can have a
conversation with a program and
oftentimes I'd have to be the middleman
between like programmer and designer and
programmer and people on my team to be
able to explain because the programmer
can't speak in business terms and I
think that's important I think you need
to know enough about your business that
not that you could step in and do
somebody's job better than them you know
I can't step in and do jobs better than
a lot of people on my team but I know
enough to be dangerous in most of those
fields and I think that's important that
you have a general understanding of how
your business works and it also gives
you guidance and instruction for
something that you may want to learn
more about you know I learned pretty
early on that I don't want to be video
editing Christina and my team does a
fantastic job when the editing and I
don't want to I don't want to learn
about it I don't want to know how to do
certain things but I could watch other
videos and say hey that's that's a cool
effect like you will bring that into our
business can we try this in our video
constantly pushing for better templates
better quality better production and
using whatever I know and whatever I'm
learning to make it better but I don't
want to go out and be edited and so I
think it's really important I think it's
really important that you spend 80 to 90
percent of your time doing the thing
that you could be great at harnessing
those skills learning as much as you can
practice in as much as you can and then
another 10 and 20% is not just doing
craft work there'll be some of that but
having a general understanding of how
your business works with the people on
your team are doing helping them get
better understanding what they're doing
so that when you have a conversation
you're not speaking totally different
languages bigger than one so the
question day today is I'm curious what
are you doing consistently to study the
game what are you doing on a regular
basis if it's daily if it's one Cleo
monthly something consistent where you
are trying to get better understanding
your craft improving your skills getting
by
consistently to drive results for
yourself and your business what does
that have it leaving the comments below
really curious in mind I also want to
give a quick shout out to Don Wagner Don
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word it really
really really means a lot to me and I
hope you enjoyed it
so thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you and I hope you continue
to believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events best
had an idea took it to the marketplace
learned how to pitch it change my
environment started hanging around
winners where the winners you know on
top the hill bro getting to the bottom
of the hill they're not the Holiday Inn
the Marriott okay they're not where my
momma told me to go my mama taught me
save everything save everything save
everything and she taught me that for
one reason because she didn't know how
to make money so what I've done but I'm
58 years old just turned 59 actually I'm
gonna spend the rest of my life helping
people figure out what I did okay
everybody should have everybody should
gonna do this everybody should have the
opportunity to take their families their
kids their wife your husband take them
wherever they want to go okay everybody
shoot this everybody does have happen
most people just are not willing to read
study learn so now if you are one of
those people here's a little warning to
you got to pick your benches carefully
I tell captain Ryan all the time I like
captain Ryan you just can't you can't
listen to everybody you can't study
everybody those of you out there there
study and you're like you're opening up
every Facebook feed every snapchat
looking at every YouTube video
you got to pick who you're gonna learn
you have to be selective if I'm if I'm
somebody did you resonate with study me
okay if I'm not if I'm not forgot then
find somebody this made it okay not just
money but has time for their family time
for vacations time for spirituality time
to take care of their physical condition
time to give back time for charity time
to help the military out those guys are
out there serving over there look find
somebody that matches your values and
study that person deep and then the last
point and this is one of my favorites
and this is one that people really miss
out on is study success successful
people study success success is not what
we naively think it's just something
that happens naturally to some people
and doesn't happen to other people
success is a very deliberate conscious
endeavor that you undertake success is
built over months and years and it's
done consciously and the more you
understand the principles of success the
concepts of success the more you study
people who have been successful the more
you see what it really takes and that
process of success the principles are
not always what they seem and to me this
is something that I really committed my
life to is studying these principles I
really love it it's exciting for me and
I really encourage you to get involved
with that so that means maybe attending
some seminars reading some books
watching these videos learning about it
maybe joining a group of friends that
are successful joining a mastermind
group right be around successful people
learn how the success process works and
learn the psychology of success not the
externals of success but the psychology
that's what we're talking about if
you're really going to get ahead you
have to study your craft you have to
deeply study it you know I I decided
what was it now 18 years ago that I
wanted to help inspire and motivate
and I wanted to coach people one-on-one
on motivation and on high performance
and I wanted to write books on the
topics so 18 years ago I started reading
a book a week on psychology leadership
communication marketing and there get on
my hand about human behavior and high
performance I was studying everything I
could in psychology every single week
now it's like people like wait you've
read a book a week for 17 years I don't
brag about I'm not like oh yeah look at
me that was for my passion I knew if I
really wanted to succeed at something I
had to study it and I had to study it
deeply and I couldn't you know spend all
this time doing other things so I had to
study in my craft the great artists of
our past history that's what they did
they did one thing they had a true level
of depth of study in that area now maybe
they dabbled in some other areas too but
they became famous because they study in
one area and so what's your area what's
what's the thing you need to study on
develop a deep level of competence into
how to do it and how that world works
because you know we have this saying in
Montana that the time to have the map is
before you enter the woods but a lot of
people have a dream and they run out
into the woods and they just start
trying stuff and they take this path and
this path and this path and this path
and because they didn't study best
practices they sundae with one you know
they wake up and they're lost they're
they're confused about who they are and
where they're at and they're in this
dark forest of the unknown with no plan
to get out they had no idea they just
jumped into something they didn't study
before taking that leap and I would say
you know it's study pay attention learn
from the best model and most intelligent
smart successful people you can in any
given area that you want to succeed in
in your life before you get into it then
develop competency by doing it over and
over and over and over again don't do it
once in a while here and there over and
over and over that's how you get
competence raise your standard Apple at
the core its core value is that people
with passion
and not one drop of myself work depends
on your acceptance of me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten most a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link in description for details